Pock, pock, pock.
Pock, pock, pock, pock, pock.
So.
Ich bin spontan am Start.
Ich weiß, es ist spät.
20.15 Uhr.
Äh, nicht 20.15 Uhr, Alter.
20.50 Uhr.
20.15 Uhr wäre noch fast normal.
20.50 Uhr ist ein bisschen...
nicht normal.
Aber sind schon die ersten Leute am Start.
Ich werde heute auch wahrscheinlich nicht so alt.
Spätestens 23 Uhr.
Aber alle, alle spätestens 23 Uhr.
Das Dumme ist wieder...
Eigentlich hatte ich vor...
Was macht mein Mauszeiger da oben eigentlich?
IQ Boost.
Pock.
Excellent.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive IQ Boost, ja.
Für alle Anwesenden.
Sind erst 27.
Rest hat Pech.
Nee, das liegt...
Nee, nee.
Bin ich nicht.
Das liegt daran.
Ich hab den ganzen Tag hier wieder vorm Rechner gehockt.
Kein Wort gesagt.
Und jetzt...
Ich rede heute zum ersten Mal.
Quasi.
Länger.
Am Stück.
Nö, nö, ist nix.
Das legt sich gleich wieder.
Kreiselcoin heute, ja.
Ich hab richtig, richtig harten Kreiselcoin gemacht.
Ich wurde geflamed ingame.
Stellt euch mal vor.
Ich wurde geflamed.
Und eigentlich liegt es mal wieder daran,
weil die Noobs den Heli geflogen sind.
Nee, aber sowas in der Richtung.
Jetzt haben wir den in den Kram nicht geschissen bekommen und ich bin einfach losgelaufen, ne.
Ist halt so.
Ich warte nicht 500 Mal, bis die Leute recouped haben.
Vor allem, wenn es ums Leveln geht.
Da renne ich halt einfach los.
Und wenn die Leute nicht hinterher kommen, obwohl ich eine Minute gewartet habe, haben sie Pech.
Ich kann ja immer eine Viertelstunde warten, bis alle sich den Finger aus dem Poppes gezogen haben.
Dann kann ich nicht mehr.
Damit sie mal wieder spielen können.
Pech gehabt.
Da muss Progress gemacht werden.
Progress.
Wenn kein Progress gemacht wird, so geht nicht der richtige Kreiselcoin.
Ja.
Wenn alle da sind, muss ich euch was sehr lustiges erzählen.
Nicht...
Betrifft mich persönlich nicht.
Hab ich vorhin gelesen.
Und ich...
Wow.
Ist ja gut.
Mach mal...
Mach die Playlist, please, noch lauter.
Ich mag Playlists nicht.
Die unterschiedlich laut sind.
Unterschiedlich laute Songs.
Das ist immer ziemlich...
Pains-Champ.
Was machen wir heute?
Guck dir den Titel an, da siehst du es.
Ich habe nichts vorbereitet.
Bei mir ist es in letzter Zeit echt schwierig.
So...
Sub...
Streams mit Technik IQ...
High IQ Substanz zu machen.
Weil da muss ich mir was überlegen.
Und ich darf auch noch nicht abends irgendwie total kaputt im Kopf sein.
Dass ich das auf die Reihe kriege.
Das ist schwierig.
Wenn ich den ganzen Tag Kreiselgrind gemacht habe, klappt das nicht.
Wenn ich arbeiten war, klappt das nicht.
Da haben sich die ganzen Reaction-Streamer einfacher.
Die müssen nächstes Mal zusammen löten oder programmieren im Stream.
Community-Gear ist am Start.
Ja.
Also Chat.
Wenn wir so...
Wenn wir über 100 Leute sind.
Das dauert ja meistens immer kurz.
Bis dann alle da sind.
Oder sagen wir mal 150 Leute.
Da muss ich euch was lustiges erzählen.
Hab ich vorhin gelesen.
Hab ich mir gedacht, das kann doch echt nicht wahr sein.
Vielleicht hat es der ein oder andere von euch auch schon mitbekommen.
Aber ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ups.
Falsches E-Mail.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe zumindest noch nichts im Chat darüber gelesen bisher.
So.
Wir machen mal kurz Archlinux by the way an.
Und installieren eine Runde Package-Updates.
Warum?
Weil Archlinux.
Sicherlich 30.000 Package-Updates gekriegt.
Pacman.
Massive geheimes Passwort.
Kommt hier nie drauf.
Wie?
Was ist das?
Nur 26 Packages.
Das ist aber schwach.
Archlinux.
Oh, was ist da oben?
Was?
Warum zum Teufel habe ich Cluster-FS installiert?
Also nicht mit C.
Ne.
Gluster.
Gluster-FS überhaupt installiert.
Blödsinn.
Habe ich jetzt seit Jahrzehnten quasi schon immer verwendet.
Kann ich mal übertrieben.
Was hast du mitbekommen?
Ne.
Warum?
Hässliche Automatenläden müssen sonntags schließen.
Ach.
Das ist bestimmt wieder gegen irgendwelche Richtlinien oder so.
Der Einzelhändler Tegut muss sich in Hessen an das Sonntagsverbot halten.
Die seelische Erhebung.
Warte mal.
Die seelische.
Was?
Die seelische Erhebung.
Ich versuche mir gerade vorzustellen, was die seelische Erhebung ist.
Die seelische Erhebung an Sonn- und Feiertagen müsste geschützt werden.
Okay.
Das ist irgendwas Gläubiges.
Pregge.
Preggetime.
Was anderes kann das nicht sein.
Ja.
Aber wo ist denn das Problem?
Da arbeitet keiner.
Da gehen die Leute rein.
Bezahlen automatisch.
Also bezahlen wahrscheinlich per Handy oder so.
Da müssen keine Leute drin sein.
Ja.
Verstehe ich das Problem.
Wisst ihr.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Ich meine.
Das ist sicherlich alles rechtlich und so.
Das muss so sein.
Aber man muss halt echt sagen.
Wir sind solche Korinthen-Kacker und Bürokratie-Liebhaber.
Hier.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Ja.
Da ist nichts geprägt.
Ist da irgendwas bekannt?
Also ich bin dafür, dass an jedem Feiertag jeder Religion automatisch keiner arbeiten muss.
Ja, bin ich sofort dabei.
Ich bin sogar dafür, dass man...
Also dann würde ich sogar selbst eine Religion gründen, wo es Feiertage gibt.
Ansonsten habe ich damit ja nichts am Hut.
Aber dafür könnte ich eine Ausnahme machen.
Denn ich glaube, dass das gar nichts mit etwas Christlichem zu tun hat.
Das Gesetz stammt vielleicht noch aus einer Zeit, wo das wichtig war.
Und das ist jetzt halt da und muss beachtet werden.
Ich glaube, da wird heute kein Hahn mehr danach krähen.
Church Champ, nicht Champ...
Church Champ machen wir, wenn schon.
Die Kirche kann viel mögen, wenn er taglang ist.
Solange es da kein Gesetz zu gibt, ist das wurscht.
Und das gibt es ja anscheinend.
Dementsprechend müssen die sich dran halten.
Dann müssen sie sich halt mal überhintern.
Und hinterfragen, ob das Gesetz so sinnvoll ist.
Beziehungsweise, ob man das nicht irgendwie ergänzen kann.
Weil prinzipiell finde ich ja schon sinnvoll, dass wir sowas wie Wochenende haben.
So, Archlinux rebooted.
Sieht gut aus.
Okay, Leute.
Ich habe ja gesagt, ich erzähle euch was Lustiges, wenn alle da sind.
Fehlen noch ein paar Leute.
Es ist...
Es ist keck...
Leute, es ist keck JavaScript-Time.
Moin, Max.
Kurze Frage.
Ich bin aktuell in der IT.
Als normaler Admin-Windows-Infrastruktur-Bereich.
Und würde gerne etwas im Coding-Bereich lernen.
Hab noch keine...
Nenn es lieber Programmieren und Softwareentwicklung.
Das Wort mag keiner.
Aber hab noch keine Ahnung, welchen Job ich danach damit machen kann.
Hast du irgendwelche Empfehlungen?
Naja, erstmal solltest du dir überlegen, was du eigentlich machen willst.
Also, was du...
Ich meine, das ist sehr vage.
Das ist genauso, wenn ich sage, ich möchte was im Admin-Bereich machen.
Das kann auch alles Mögliche sein.
Also, was dir gefällt.
Ich meine, es gibt...
Es gibt ja nicht nur Backend-Frontend.
So als Unterscheidung.
Je nach Technologie.
Du hast ja ganz viele Sachen.
Backend, Frontend, Mobile.
Irgendwelche Server-Geschichten.
Cloud-Native-Sachen.
Tools.
Unterschiedlichsten Frameworks.
Unterschiedlichen Sprachen.
Musst du erstmal überlegen, was du machen willst.
Host.
Ja.
Gibt noch Leute, die machen Cobol.
Ihr benutzt jetzt Slack auf der Arbeit.
Max, nee, machen wir nicht.
Wie kommst du da drauf?
Aber keck JavaScript.
Leute, ich wollte warten, bis alle da sind.
Es sind noch nicht alle da.
Aber ich muss euch das jetzt erzählen, weil ich habe mich so kaputt gelacht vorhin.
Das ist so typisch keck JavaScript.
Chat, nicht nachgucken.
Nicht nachgucken.
Jeder kann einfach nachgucken.
Sagt euch...
Moment.
Fuck.
Okay, jetzt kann ich.
Also, sagt euch...
Everything, das NPM-Package, Everything, was?
Nicht nachgucken.
Ich will einfach nur wissen, ob ihr es mitbekommen habt.
Es ist wieder komplettes JavaScript.
Es ist wieder kompletter JavaScript-Schwachsinn.
Also, ich erkläre euch das mal kurz in meinen Worten.
Da gucken wir uns auch nochmal irgendwie Newsartikel dazu an.
Also, ihr kennt ja alle, zumindest alle, die ein bisschen was mit...
Ist das so eine Joke-Package wie Not Even?
Ja, aber schlimmer.
Also, ihr kennt ja wahrscheinlich alle, die ein bisschen was Frontend-mäßiges bisher gemacht haben.
Ihr kennt wahrscheinlich NPM.
NPM ist zwei Dinger.
NPM ist eine Package Registry für JavaScript-Packages.
Und gleichermaßen auch das offizielle Node.js.
Package Manager Tool.
So, das Ding ist folgendes.
Hier kann jeder Depp hingehen und Packages veröffentlichen.
Was auch okay ist, ja.
Ich meine, da gibt es dann so tolle Sachen wie Is Even als Package zum Beispiel.
Was drei Zeilen im Endeffekt enthält.
Was nur 162.000 oder nur 163.000 Weekly.
Weekly Downloads hat.
Also, das ist mehr, als ich aktuell auf YouTube Views in der Woche habe.
Wenn ich mal was hochladen würde, dann ist es zwar ein bisschen mehr, aber...
Ja, so.
Und jetzt ist das so, dass vor ein paar Jahren...
Vielleicht kann sich da noch einer dran erinnern.
Vor ein paar Jahren hat einer mal ein Package unpublished.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, welches Package das war, aber das war ein Package...
Äh, Leftshift.
Leftshift war das Package.
Jetzt weiß ich es ja.
Left... oder?
Shift... ne, ne, Leftshift hieß das, glaube ich.
Das war so ein Mini-Package.
Irgendjemand, äh, also quasi...
Der Typ ist hier hingegangen, vor zig Jahren hat er das Package hochgeladen.
Und ganz viele andere Packages hatten das als Dependency drin.
Nicht Is Even, sondern ein anderes.
Und der hat dann sein Package unpublished und gelöscht auf npm.
Daraufhin ist das halbe Internet zusammengebrochen, weil irgend so ein random Dude in drei Zeilen JavaScript Package gelöscht hat.
So, und daraufhin ist npm hingegangen und hat gesagt, hey...
...das ist alles ein Package, was ihr benötigt.
Also, das heißt, wenn es Dependencies auf eine Package-Version gibt, dann darf diese Package-Version nicht mehr gelöscht werden, selbst vom Maintainer.
Also, mal angenommen, um das jetzt mal, um das jetzt mal, äh, euch zu, zu erklären.
Also, mal angenommen, ihr veröffentlicht ein Package mit der Versi, mit der Version 0.5.
Und irgendjemand auf der Welt verwendet dieses Package mit Version 0.5.
Und ihr habt festgestellt, ihr habt zufä...
Ihr habt zuf...
Ihr habt zufällig eure private Handynummer mit committet.
In den Vorderoks.
In den Vorderok.
Source-Code oder irgendwas, wo ihr garantiert
nicht wollt, dass das irgendjemand sieht.
Committed.
Oder mitgepublished in dem Package.
Ja, wie der Chrome-Typ,
der irgendwelche, ähm, was war das?
Furry-Porn-Bilder
in seinem Chromium-Fork
drin hatte. So. Stellt euch mal vor,
ihr habt zufälligerweise ein Package,
Version 0.5 veröffentlicht
und, äh, ja, ja, genau, das
meine ich. Ja, und habt da zufälligerweise
warum auch immer Furry-Porn mit
committet. So. Und da wollt ihr das Package
wieder unpublishen. Und dann geht
das nicht, das Package zu unpublishen,
weil, naja, es gibt eine
Dependency auf das Package.
Das heißt, ihr kriegt das nicht mehr raus.
So. Und jetzt,
und jetzt kommt der, und jetzt kommt der Hit,
jetzt kommt der Witz an der ganzen Sache.
Irgendjemand hat sich jetzt einen Spaß
draus gemacht und hat ein
NPM-Package erstellt, was
alle weiteren NPM-Packages
als Dependency erhält. Der hat quasi
die komplette NPM-Registry durchgecrawled
und hat
jedes Package, egal wie alt,
egal wie maintained, egal wer es ist,
jedes Package, also
hunderte, tausende,
zehntausende Packages
als Dependency eingetragen
und hat dieses Package
veröffentlicht. Und jetzt dürft ihr
mal raten, was passiert ist.
Richtig feifert der Dude. Da kann man
sich, also, das erste ist,
das erste ist, man sollte
nicht auf die Idee kommen, dieses Package zu installieren,
weil das hier jede SSD und
alles, was es auf der Welt gibt, sprengt.
Du installierst damit wirklich sprichwörtlich
das Internet, wenn du NPM
Install Everything gemacht hast.
Ja, das kannst du vergessen.
Also, GitHub, Everything,
JS, wir können uns das auch hier kurz angucken.
Das gibt es nicht bei das Repo, das wurde
ne, öh,
ne, ne, NPM.
Das wurde gelöscht mittlerweile, es ist
weg. Wir können noch
die Cache-Seite angucken.
Die gibt es witzigerweise
noch.
Also, NPM Install
Everything. Er hat extra
hingeschrieben, Achtung, Warnung,
Achtung, Warnung,
Don't Install This.
So, jetzt gab es bloß ein Problem.
Jetzt gab es bloß,
pass mal auf, das allerlustigste
kommt zum Schluss. So, und jetzt gab es
ein Problem.
Dadurch, dass der jedes, egal
wie kleine Furz-Package auf einmal
als Dependency drin hatte, konnten
ganz viele Leute
ihre Packages auf NPM nicht mehr.
Ja, wie heißt
das? Die Listen, die, die
die Subscriben
löschen.
Ja, auf gut Deutsch. Das hat natürlich
viele Leute abgefuckt, weil da haben
irgendwelche Leute
Tests anpublishen, ja, die
publishen. Da haben viele Leute halt einfach
Testsachen hochgepusht
und wollten es halt nie veröffentlichen. So,
konnten sie nicht mehr löschen, wegen NPM Policy.
Das hat wieder richtig
Probleme in der JavaScript-Welt verursacht.
Und jetzt kommt's.
Und jetzt kommt's. Da musste ich mich so
wegpissen, Freund.
Irgendwann hat der Typ das dann kapiert, dass es
keine allzu gute Idee war,
das, äh,
so ein Everything-Package zu veröffentlichen.
Und wisst ihr,
was er dann machen wollte?
Wisst ihr, was er dann machen wollte?
Nachdem er festgestellt hat, dass es eine dumme Idee war,
das JavaScript-Ökosystem
lahmzulegen.
Er wollte das Package löschen.
Das ging aber nicht,
weil es
schon Leute als Dependency drin hatten.
Es ging nicht mehr weg.
Es war für immer da.
Kein JavaScript, Alter.
Da musste ich mich so wegschmeißen, Freund.
Naja, zumindest,
es ging dann doch
glimpflich aus.
Es ging dann doch glimpflich aus, denn
es wurde von
von einem NPM-Mods
wurde das dann wieder entfernt.
Er hat das Github-Report auch gelöscht.
Aber das ist, also ganz ehrlich,
JavaScript-Package-Management, das ist
so eine Shitshow.
Das ist absoluter Wahnsinn, Alter.
Ich mein,
nicht nur, dass wenn du
bei irgendeinem popeligen Projekt, NPM,
bei Rust ist es ja fast schon genauso schlimm mittlerweile.
Ja, wenn du da irgendwie so was machst, das ist ja fast schon genauso schlimm mittlerweile.
Ja, wenn du da irgendwie so was machst, das ist ja fast schon so schlimm mittlerweile.
NPM installiert in einem neuen geklonten Projekt,
dann 1500 Packages bekommst,
3,5 Gig Node Models,
3,5 Gig Node Models ist wahrscheinlich noch relativ wenig.
Dazu kommt noch,
dass ganz lange NPM
irgendwelche lokalen Build-Scripts ausgeführt hat.
Weiß irgendjemand, ob das immer noch so ist?
Also du konntest ja total easy
irgendwelche Malware verbreiten früher mit NPM.
Weil einfach Post-Install-Scripts ausgeführt wurden.
Und dann stand da drinnen,
ja, lade Malware.exe runter und führ aus.
So, und mal gucken,
ob Golem oder so noch ein bisschen...
When everything becomes too much.
Socket.dev klingt wie nach irgendeiner...
Kennt die Seite jemand?
Klingt wie irgendeine AI-generierte Sache, aber...
Everything Package contains 3000 plus Sub-Packages,
die selbst wiederum Dependencies enthalten.
Das finde ich auch geil.
Der Autor,
der Autor selbst hat diese Domain hier sich gekauft
und dort dann quasi Sachen gepostet,
was er für Chaos verursacht hat.
Und dann wollte er es löschen.
Genau.
Ironically, the policy trapped in its own...
Er hat festgestellt,
dass es keine doofe Idee ist.
Und dann wollte er sein Everything Package entfernen,
aber es ging nicht.
Und dann hat er die NPM-Mods angeschrieben.
Und die NPM-Mods, die haben es dann wahrscheinlich
irgendwie nicht mehr.
Irgendwann wieder gefixt.
Es ist...
Also, JavaScript-Ökosystem ist halt echt...
Riesenschitschau.
Ach, da gibt's ein Video zu.
Interessant.
Naja, das ist...
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich meine, wir müssen die Story jetzt nicht über 30 Minuten ausdehnen.
Aber ich find's geil.
Lass das mal wieder...
Es ist doch...
Es vergeht kein Monat,
bis nicht irgendwelche JavaScripts
NPM-Mods...
...weirde Sachen passieren.
Das war aber echt massive keck JavaScript.
Gehen meine Emotes zwar wieder nicht?
Keck JavaScript?
Doch, geht doch.
Oh ja, keck JavaScript.
Da kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Wie war Weihnachten und Silvester?
Weihnachtlich und silvesterisch.
Was soll ich dazu sagen?
Das war...
Viel gefressen hab ich.
Massive.
Ich hab sogar wieder ein bisschen zugenommen.
Massive gefressen hab ich.
Ultra viel gefressen hab ich.
Ist jetzt aber schon wieder ein bisschen besser.
Und...
Morgen früh...
...mach ich zum ersten Mal wieder meine 11 Kilometer Runde.
Übrigens, heute war kurz 1.1.1.1 weg.
Ist das auch jemand aufgefallen?
Mal gucken, ob's da...
Gibt's dazu irgendwelche News, dass der DNS weg war?
Der war nämlich heute kurz weg.
Nö.
Nicht dazu.
Der war heute kurz weg.
Kurzzeitig für eine halbe Minute oder für eine Minute nicht erreichbar.
1.1.1.1.
Vielleicht war auch der Server selbst.
Ich mein, das sind mehrere weltweit.
Relativ sicher.
Vielleicht war es auch irgendeine Routing-Geschichte.
Das ist ja garantiert per Anycast geregelt.
Die Erreichbarkeit von 1.1.1.1.
GitHub war...
Ach, mal wieder.
Mal wieder.
Ja, okay.
Ja.
Einer hat Startcoin in ein Package gepufft.
Das ist eine Dependency auf vielen Riesenprojekten.
Okay.
Also, was ich mal mitbekommen habe, ist, dass irgendjemand...
Ein...
Was war das?
Donation-Aufruf?
Oder...
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war.
Und da war auch...
Da war auch riesen Shitstorm am Start.
Und es gab mal den Fall, dass irgendjemand...
Versuch...
Genau!
Jetzt weiß ich's wieder.
Irgendjemand hat doch auch mal in sein Package eingebaut.
Aber das war ein .NET-Package.
Also, man sieht, das kann auch...
Das muss nicht zwangsläufig immer JavaScript sein.
Das war ein .NET-Package.
Ich hab vergessen, was das genau gewesen ist.
Mock.
Mock war das.
Es hat irgendjemand in sein .NET-Package eingebaut,
dass die E-Mail-Adresse, wenn man sich in einem Git-Repo befindet,
die E-Mail-Adresse ausgelesen wird.
Und gehasht zu irgendeinem Service geschickt wird.
Das war Mock, glaube ich.
Was ist da eigentlich rausgekommen?
Es wird wahrscheinlich immer noch verwendet.
Was ich auch...
Wo ich mir auch denke, die ganzen Leute da...
Aber die sind wieder komplett übers Ziel rausgeschossen auch.
Es war eine blöde Idee.
Es war eine wirklich...
Das wurde wieder rausgebaut.
Aha.
Ich meine, es war eine blöde Idee.
Aber die Leute haben es wieder komplett übertrieben mit dem Rumgeflame.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Komplett übertrieben.
Ich hab heute wieder einen YouTube-Comment gekriegt, wo ich mir gedacht hab...
Manche Leute...
Haben echt krasse Fantasie.
Ja.
Es ging...
Es war unter diesem...
Es war unter diesem Video hier.
Linux ist kein Ersatz für Windows.
Da krieg ich ja übrigens regelmäßig Kommentare.
Das sind relativ viele Kommentare.
Krieg ich ja immer noch regelmäßig, fast täglich...
Okay, hier mal zwischendrinig.
Aber zwischenzeitlich immer wieder Kommentare,
wo sich dann entweder Leute das Video nicht richtig angeguckt haben,
oder aber irgendwelche Leute, die...
Ja, sich das Video nicht richtig angeguckt haben.
Oder 30 Sekunden.
Und dann irgendwelche Sachen hier von sich geben, wo ich immer denke,
das hat doch mit dem Video überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Und außerdem hab ich das überhaupt nicht so gesagt, wie ihr das da schon...
Egal.
Zumindest heute...
Heute kam er hier.
Speedy.
Speedy 47.
Und der hat wirklich den Vogel abgeschossen mit diesem Kommentar.
Das muss ich euch hier mal zeigen.
Das muss ich jetzt mal hier zum Besten geben.
Das ist eines der weirdesten Kommentare, die ich in letzter Zeit auf YouTube gekriegt hab.
Passt mal auf.
Also es geht, wie gesagt, in dem Video geht es darum, dass Linux kein Ersatz für Windows ist.
Was hast du geantwortet?
Sehen wir gleich.
Also, er schreibt hier...
Allein schon der Smile hier, ne?
Also er fängt hier an mit...
Eine einfache zu bedienende User-Oberfläche
hat eigentlich nur Nachteile,
und gilt alles nur zur Unterhaltung.
Unterhalten.
Smiley.
Die Frage, also das ist...
Moment, Leute. Das ist Big Kek Alu Time.
Das gesamte Ding, ja?
Massive Kek Alu.
Die Frage ist nichts Windows-Linux, sondern es geht um die Kompetenz der Menschen.
Okay, ja, das mag es tatsächlich sein.
Ähm, Win und das...
Komma.
Und das OS von Apple...
Die Musik passt eigentlich ganz gut.
Win und das OS von Apple sind...
sind ja auch behindertengerecht gemacht,
damit jeder Vollidiot ein Rechnen bedienen kann
und sich die wahnsinnige Unterhaltung reinziehen kann.
Ich habe bis 20 PC programmiert.
Das war mir zu einfach, glaube ich sofort.
Too easy.
Das war mir zu einfach und zu langweilig.
Denn Rechner macht immer, was man ihm sagt.
Dann habe ich damit angefangen, Menschen zu programmieren.
Alles klar, okay, okay.
Alles klar.
Das war im Discord, ja, das habe ich im Discord gepostet.
So.
Am Anfang etwas schwieriger.
Als ein Rechner.
Aber mit der Zeit wesentlich einfacher.
Denn ich muss nur schauen, dass die Menschen sich immer und immer wieder denselben Scheiß ansehen.
Was übrigens alles sehr viel mit Linux ist, kein Ersatz für Windows zu tun hat.
So.
Und jetzt geht es richtig los.
Was ich wohl damit sagen will.
Ja, das frage ich mich tatsächlich auch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihm selbst klar ist, was er damit sagen will.
Was ich wohl damit sagen will.
Die Frage ist nicht, ob Win oder Linux,
sondern die Frage ist, wozu brauche ich einen Rechner, um mich klein zu halten.
Nachrichten, Textverarbeitung, Kapitalismus.
Das Kommentar könnte auch schon wieder...
Wisst ihr, normalerweise denke ich, sowas ist getrollt.
Sowas ist halt einfach jebaited.
Im Zweifelsfall, dass ich es lustig finde.
Aber das ist so abgedreht, das glaube ich schon wieder.
Das glaube ich schon wieder fast, dass er das ernst meint.
Kapitalismus.
Fragt euch mal, ob es das braucht.
Eine Rechenmaschine ist nichts anderes, als dazu da, die Menschen zu knechten.
Sie mit dummer Unterhaltung und Beschäftigung.
Also ist ein Rechner nichts anderes, als ein Compiler, um euch zu programmieren.
Es gibt auch sinnvolle Aufgaben von Rechner.
Aber für diese Aufgaben braucht man weder ein Betriebssystem, noch einen Monitor.
Ah ja, alles klar.
Als Antwort ist mir da auch nichts anderes dazu eingefallen.
Alles klar.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Also jetzt wissen wir auch, ein Rechner ist dazu da, um euch zu kompilieren.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit dem los ist.
Das ist wirklich eines der geilsten Comments in letzter Zeit gewesen.
Normalerweise falle ich auf so Sachen nur noch schwierig rein.
Weil ich die meisten Sachen schlicht ergreifend gar nicht für voll nehme und nicht glaube, was sie sind.
Ich gehe immer davon aus, dass das kein Rechner ist.
Ich weiß nicht, woher das kommt.
Ich gehe immer davon aus, dass das Getrolle ist.
Aber das ist so abgedreht, da muss sich einer entweder extrem viel Mühe gegeben haben, dass ich es quasi nicht erkenne als G-Bait oder sonst was.
Und dann hat er es fast schon verdient, dass man darauf eingeht.
Oder er meint es ernst.
Und ich vermute, er meint es ernst.
Das ist auch nicht AI geschrieben.
Das sieht nicht nach einem typischen AI Text aus.
Ich habe mal ein neues Video hochgenommen und hochgeladen.
Aber nicht freigeschaltet, weil das viel zu spät gewesen wäre.
Als wäre dann erst um 17, 18 Uhr oder so oben.
Ich meine, du kannst ChatGPT bestimmt sagen, mache random Rechtschreibfehler.
Ja.
Also ich würde mich bevorzugt von einem IBM Großrechner mal kompilieren lassen.
Um auch zu wissen, wie das ist.
Also denkt dran, Rechner sind nur da, um euch zu kompilieren.
Also die Leute muss man echt sagen, habe ich ja auch auf Twitter geschrieben.
Sorry, auf X.
Manche Leute haben echt wilde Fantasien.
Also ich weiß nicht, was mit denen los ist.
Challenge, except if Versuchung mit ChatGPT eine ähnlich wäre.
Ich glaube, dafür sagt die AI noch.
Ich glaube, das kriegt ChatGPT noch nicht so hin.
Hat nicht oben jemand was gefragt?
Wollte ich noch was zu sagen?
Was hältst du von Jobhopping?
Also zwei bis drei Jahre wechseln und sein Gehalt zu steigern, wenn du damit dein Gehalt steigern kannst, warum nicht?
Also wenn das für dich die Priorität Nummer eins ist, warum nicht?
Ich denke immer, Gehalt ist, okay, ich muss das anders sagen, Gehalt ist wahrscheinlich für jeden Priorität eins.
Oder, Tschetke, meine Frage an euch.
An alle, die, wenn es nicht eure Firma ist, ja, alle, die irgendwo angestellt sind, arbeiten, was ist für euch, oder ist für jemand von euch Gehalt nicht Nummer eins von der Wichtigkeit her?
Letztendlich sind wir uns ja einig, das Gesamtpaket muss stimmen, aber wenn man das mal, wenn man das mal so abstufen würde, würde ich sagen, Gehalt ist auf jeden Fall Stufe eins, ja.
Natürlich ist das alles immer ein bisschen gestaffelt, also wenn es bei einem jetzt ein Euro mehr gibt und der Rest scheiße ist,
gehe ich trotzdem nicht dahin, nur weil es ein Euro mehr, wisst ihr, Obstkorb, ja, verstehe ich.
Ja gut, das ist, das ist ja auch, also, aber ich denke mal, prinzipiell ist Gehalt erstmal Nummer eins bei dem, was man, bei den Sachen, dass man guckt.
Und wenn das dein, dein Ziel ist, in, möglichst schnell, da, gehaltstechnisch aufzusteigen, also, ich, ich sehe da kein Problem drin.
Du bist ja mit dem Laden nicht verheiratet, du kannst das ja einfach machen.
Wenn du was Gutes, Neues findest, also, ich finde das nicht verwerflich.
Für mich, ich hätte,
keinen Bock drauf, ja, ich meine, zwei bis drei Jahren, das ist so die Zeit, wo man sich so richtig dran gewöhnt hat, weiß, wie es in dem jeweiligen Laden läuft,
ähm, sich ein bisschen, was die organisatorischen Sachen angeht, zurücklehnen kann, weil man nicht jetzt laufen gucken muss, wie geht was,
du weißt, wie die Sachen gemacht werden, wie die Prozesse laufen, wen du für was fragen willst, äh, wen du für was fragen musst, wenn du was wissen willst.
Also, nach zwei bis drei Jahren ist es meistens dann deutlich gechillter nochmal, deswegen dann gerade wechseln, aber,
wenn man das von, von den Skills her machen kann, wenn das von der persönlichen, ja, so, so, Lebensplanung und so passt und das Wichtigste ist, das Gehalt zu steigern möglichst schnell,
dann ist das bestimmt nicht verkehrt, also, ich finde da überhaupt nichts Verwerfliches dran.
Warum fragst du, willst du das machen?
Wieder Job wechseln, du hast doch erst, du hast ja nicht letztens erst geschrieben, du hast einen neuen Job.
Ich bilde mir ein, oder zumindest, ich weiß nicht, ob es du das warst, aber irgendjemand, der einen ähnlichen Namen hatte, glaube ich.
Also, insofern, ja, also, ich finde es, ich finde es nicht verwerflich.
Du hast ja, du bist seit drei Monaten im neuen Laden, siehst du, da habe ich, das, das dachte ich mir doch.
Also, ich finde da überhaupt nichts Verwerfliches dran.
Man darf, man muss das immer so sehen, also, wie gesagt, für mich persönlich wäre das jetzt nicht unbedingt was, aber, man muss es mal so sehen, umgedreht,
würden es die meisten Arbeitgeber mit euch auch machen, wenn es irgendwelche Probleme gibt, wenn irgendwas nicht passt, dann würden die auch sagen, ey, hier, macht schon mal vom Acker.
Also, warum solltest du das nicht auch machen?
Ich sehe da überhaupt nichts Verwerfliches dran, für mich, für mich persönlich wäre das jetzt nichts.
Freizeit, Arbeitszeit ist wichtiger.
Ja, ich meine, wie gesagt, so sehe ich das ja auch, dass das Gesamtpaket stimmen muss, aber von der Priorität her ist bei mir Gehalt schon das, das Überste.
Fast gleichauf bei Gehalt ist mittlerweile bei mir tatsächlich Homeoffice, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Also, ich würde sogar, ich würde sogar auf bisschen Gehalt verzichten, wenn ich dadurch quasi bessere Homeoffice-Möglichkeiten hätte, aber die habe ich bei mir.
Ich kriege jetzt ja viel Kohle und habe gute Homeoffice-Regelungen, aber ich würde sogar auf ein bisschen Geld verzichten, wenn die Homeoffice-Regelungen gut sind.
Allerdings jetzt auch nicht auf viel, da würde ich halt einfach nicht hingehen, wenn es nicht passt.
Also, da muss schon grundsätzlich die Kohle stimmen, Homeoffice stimmen, das sind so meine zwei wichtigsten Punkte.
Homeoffice muss möglich sein, denn Bahn fahren öfters gerade, ihr müsst euch mal überlegen, ich wäre fast nach Würzburg gegangen in der Firma.
Da hatte ich zwar auch fast dauerhaft Homeoffice.
Aber, da hätte ich ab und zu nach Würzburg fahren müssen und da hätte mich die Bahn sicherlich extremst abgefuckt, Alter.
Weil will ich Bayern, ja?
Da habe ich einen Tag mehr Urlaub.
Okay, Quade.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Also, ich würde nicht Windows administrieren, egal wie viel Geld.
Ne, das würde ich nicht sagen.
Also, wenn mir einer extrem viel Geld bezahlt dafür und dem klar ist, dass ich keine Ahnung von Windows-Administration habe, dann würde ich auch Windows administrieren.
Leute, ich bin da konfrontiert.
Das ist einfach teuflisch, ich habe kein Problem damit, aber der müsste mir dann wirklich schon enorm viel Geld bezahlen.
Also, wenn da jetzt einer sagt, Max, 300.000 Euro im Jahr, 350.000, na, sag mal 350.000 Euro im Jahr und du machst Windows für mich, dann würde ich Windows machen, kein Problem.
Also, wenn mir einer dreimal mehr bietet, ungefähr knapp, dreimal mehr bietet als das, was ich jetzt bekomme, dann administriere ich auch Windows, habe ich kein Problem dafür.
Also, wenn mir einer dreimal mehr bietet, ungefähr knapp, dreimal mehr bietet als das, was ich jetzt bekomme, dann administriere ich auch Windows.
50.000 Euro? Nein, auf gar keinen Fall.
Dafür nicht, dafür nicht.
Du meinst die Kommentare unter dem Video hier?
Die sind, die sind
unter dem Video hier?
Unter dem, wo ich eben war, die sind
massive cringe.
Das ist wirklich schrecklich.
Was wäre die wichtige Homeoffice
oder 4-Tage-Woche?
Das ist schwierig.
Das ist wirklich nicht so einfach, die Frage.
Also,
jetzt mal Disclaimer, die Frage wird sich bei mir
gar nicht stellen, weil ich würde einfach nirgends
wohin gehen, wo es das eine und das andere
oder das andere nicht gibt.
Aber gehen wir jetzt mal von aus, das ist keine
Option und ich müsste mich dafür
entscheiden, ja? Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
müsste ich mich entscheiden für einen Laden
mit Homeoffice, wo ich 5 Tage
arbeiten müsste versus einen Tag,
4 Tage und kein Homeoffice.
Dann würde ich wahrscheinlich,
dann würde ich wahrscheinlich sagen Homeoffice.
Dann würde ich sagen Homeoffice
ist mir lieber als 4-Tage-Woche.
Allein schon das Gefahre, was man
sich erspart, ist ja auch einiges an Zeit.
Was bringt dir eine 4-Tage-Woche, wenn die
andere 4 Tage, 2 Stunden
am Tag damit verbringst, auch durch die Landschaft
zu fahren? Dann lieber 5 Tage
und Homeoffice.
Aber
insgesamt würde ich zu keinem Laden mehr gehen,
der nicht beides ermöglicht.
Wie gesagt, ich arbeite seit wann?
Seit 2012 oder so
jetzt? 13 irgendwie? Ich weiß
es gar nicht. Teilzeit,
ich kann mir das gar nicht mehr vorstellen. Leute, ich hab
absolut keine Ahnung, wie ich das damals
geschafft habe.
Aufzustehen so früh,
mit dem Bus und der Bahn
nach Frankfurt zu fahren, das
jeden Tag
und auch noch 5 Tage
die Woche. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das gemacht habe.
Es ist mir komplett unverständlich.
Keine Ahnung, wie ich das überlebt. Gut, ich meine,
lang habe ich das ja auch nicht gemacht.
Lang habe ich das
nicht gemacht. Ich meine,
ich mache es halt ungefähr
2013, 4-Tage-Woche.
Das heißt,
2013 ist
dann habe ich quasi 5 Jahre
richtig gearbeitet.
So mit 5-Tage-Woche. Und dann
habe ich 4-Tage-Woche gemacht.
Easy life.
Ja, also ich würde mich
für den Homeoffice-Laden entscheiden,
wenn ich müsste. Wie gesagt, ich würde normalerweise
gar nicht hingehen, aber wenn es jetzt wirklich die Frage ist,
das eine oder das andere, aus irgendwelchen Gründen
muss das sein, dann würde ich den Homeoffice-Laden
nehmen.
Was hältst du von der Idee,
in Teilzeit zu gehen, mit dem Ziel, in der
Freizeit mehr zu lernen, um einen Job zu finden?
Ganz ehrlich,
unabhängig davon,
was dein Ziel ist mit Teilzeit,
wenn du dir das leisten kannst,
kann ich dir das immer nur empfehlen.
Egal, was du in deiner Freizeit machen willst.
In deiner Freizeit was zu lernen,
ist sicherlich sehr sinnvoll.
Mache ich ja auch.
Also das meiste an
Technik-Know-How, was neuere Sachen
angeht, habe ich tatsächlich
aufgebaut, unabhängig von der Arbeit.
Ich habe vieles von dem
dann über die Jahre hinweg
bei der Arbeit gebraucht,
und konnte das dann auch in der Praxis
mir angucken, sodass das in der Theorie
manchmal nicht so ganz damit übereinstimmt,
wie es dann wirklich ist.
Aber ich kann es dir nur empfehlen.
Vier-Tage-Woche ist das Beste.
Wisst ihr, bei der Vier-Tage-Woche,
was da immer vergessen wird, ist,
man hat nicht nur drei Tage
am Stück frei.
Oder je nachdem, wie man den freien Tag legt.
Sagen wir mal, ihr nehmt Montag oder Freitag.
Wisst ihr, man hat nicht nur
drei Tage am Stück frei.
Man muss auch einen Tag weniger
arbeiten.
Das muss einem da immer klar sein bei.
Weil viele Leute denken sich im Kopf so,
ach, der eine Tag mehr, das macht's doch
auch nicht aus, und dafür auf Geld verzichten.
Nein, nein. Es ist nicht nur der eine Tag.
Es ist ein Tag frei mehr
und ein Tag arbeiten weniger.
Weil es ist ja nicht so, dass die Woche
danach acht Tage hätte
und du hast drei Tage frei.
Nein, du hast dann drei Tage frei,
vier Tage arbeiten. Es sind weiterhin sieben Tage.
Und dementsprechend bist du auch
deutlich weniger kaputt, weil dir
nur vier Tage anstatt fünf Tage arbeiten
musstest. Und dann hast du am Stück
der nächste Schritt, drei Tage Woche,
bedeutet schon wieder, dass du vier Tage
frei hast und drei Tage arbeiten musstest.
Es ist immer ein Tag mehr frei und
ein Tag weniger arbeiten. Das heißt, dieser eine
Tag bringt
dadurch, dass er eben
doppelte Vorzüge hat.
Den Tag musst du weniger arbeiten
und den Tag hast du mehr frei.
So viel mehr
Entspannung, das ist
aus meiner Sicht 20%
Gehalteinbuß mehr als wert.
Durch Steuer ist es gar nicht ganz so viel
weniger, aber auch nicht bedeutend.
Also
ungefähr plus minus ein bisschen
20%.
Und
mir geht es
so viel besser mit vier Tagen als mit
fünf Tagen. Ich kann das
jedem empfehlen, der sich das irgendwie finanziell
leisten kann.
Man teilt davon nur nicht vergessen, dass man später weniger Rente
bekommt. Das ist richtig.
Deswegen habe ich auch meine ETF-Stonks.
Ich habe die
Altersvorsorge vom alten Arbeitgeber,
die ich ein paar Jahre gemacht habe, die Altersvorsorge
vom neuen Arbeitgeber,
meine ETF-Stonks
plus noch ein paar andere Sachen
und die 5,50 Euro,
die ich gesetzlich Rente kriege irgendwann,
die fallen dann hoffentlich gar nicht mehr.
Die sind nice to have.
Wie werden die Urlaubstage eigentlich beeinflusst?
Die werden weniger, anteilmäßig. Du kriegst 20%
weniger Urlaub. Ich habe
24 Tage, andere haben
30 Tage, glaube ich.
Oder?
Ja, passt doch. 20% von
30, genau.
Ich würde kein First Level Support für 150k
machen. Der Madminister
schreibt, bei ihm steht dieses Jahr der nächste
Gehaltssprung an. Ich bin
überlegt, sogar abzuholen. Warum?
Weil ich aktuell genug verdiene und
keine Großverhandlungen, gute Arbeitsbedingungen.
Ach so!
Ja, nee, dann. Also,
wenn mit dem Gehaltssprung so Sachen
verbunden sind, die man nicht machen möchte,
dann würde ich... Okay, dann verstehe ich.
Dann gehe ich das. Dann geht es ja aber nicht darum,
dass du einen Gehaltssprung, dass du quasi
eine Gehaltserhöhung ablehnst. Es geht darum,
du lehnst ab, eine andere,
quasi deinen Job zu wechseln,
in eine andere Position, oder dass du
auf eine andere Position wechseln willst,
lehnst du ab, was mit
einem Gehaltssprung verbunden wäre.
Also, es ist jetzt ja nicht so, dass einer
sagt, hier, du kriegst 20.000 Euro
mehr und du sagst, nö, hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Es kommt einer zu dir und sagt, ey,
du musst Führungskraft werden, dann kriegst du 20.000
Euro mehr und du sagst, nö, hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Also, das ist ja was anderes
und das kann ich voll und ganz verstehen.
Da hätte ich auch
überhaupt gar keinen Bock drauf.
Auf der alten Arbeit, der Chef hat mir immer
versucht, die Karrieremöglichkeiten nahezulegen
und was es hier nicht noch alles gibt und was man tolles
machen kann. Irgendwann hat er es auch gelernt.
Ich bin niemand, der
Karriere im klassischen Sinn machen will
mit Management-Shit
oder sonst was. Es ist aber einfach so,
ich verstehe auch gar nicht, warum das in so vielen Unternehmen
noch der Fall ist. Es ist einfach so,
es gibt ganz wenige IT-Leute, die
gute Manager sind.
Dementsprechend gibt es auch wenig Manager, die gute
IT-Leute sind. Die sollen alle das machen,
was sie gut können
und dann ist wahrscheinlich allen
am besten geholfen bei.
Dementsprechend sind Unternehmen gut,
die es mittlerweile gecheckt haben,
dass man Leuten Karrieremöglichkeiten
bieten muss, außerhalb von
Projektmanagement und Führungsverantwortung.
Bei vielen Unternehmen hast du ja
mittlerweile so drei Karrieremöglichkeiten.
Du hast einmal so Personal,
Führungsverantwortung,
Personalverantwortung, Teamleiter
und der klassische
Karriereweg, den viele früher auch so
als einziges hatten, gibt es immer noch.
Dann hast du was Richtung Projekte
und Projektmanagement. Das ist der zweite
Karriereweg, den es in vielen Unternehmen gibt.
Und der dritte ist tatsächlich für die ganzen Techniker
und Programmierer
irgendwelche fachlichen
Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten.
Vom Anwendungsentwickler zum
Senior-Anwendungsentwickler zum
Architekt zu solchen Geschichten.
Und das finde ich sinnvoll,
weil dann kann man weiterhin
das machen, was man gut kann, wo man Bock
drauf hat. Und man hat
trotzdem Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
und man muss sich nicht mit diesem Blödsinn
hier auseinandersetzen. Das ist einfach für die
meisten nix. Die meisten können es
auch nicht.
Muss einfach immer gucken, wo die Stärken sind.
Würdest du Windows-Systeme
für die IHK administrieren?
Ja, für sehr viel
Geld schon.
Es steigt natürlich
immer mehr, was es sein muss,
ja. Bei dir ist nix mehr mit
Homeoffice, Sengi. Dann hat er
Pech und muss damit rechnen, dass ihm die Leute
wegrennen. Du kannst jetzt gerade
in der IT, kannst du dir das heutzutage gar nicht
mehr so sehr aussuchen, wie sich das viele Leute
vorstellen. So nach dem Motto,
ja, wir sind ja, wisst ihr, ich hab
manchmal das Gefühl, viele Unternehmen sind da noch ein bisschen
so im letzten Jahrtausend fast schon stecken geblieben.
Das sieht man auch an den Stellenanzeigen.
So, wir sind die geilsten,
ihr kennt doch die üblichen
Stellenanzeigen. Wir sind Firma XY,
äh, Marktführer,
im Bereich sowieso, das schreiben
wir alle, äh, modernes, dynamisches
Team, bla bla bla, wir freuen uns auf
ihre aussagekräftige Bewerbung, so.
Wo du dir dann denkst, okay, schön, dass ihr euch
darauf freut, aber ich bewerbe mich nicht bei euch.
Hahaha.
Weil nichts von der Anzeige spricht
mich an. Und die haben's
doch gar nicht gecheckt, dass man sich da vielleicht auch ein bisschen
Mühe geben muss. Ja, und
dementsprechend können sich viele Unternehmen heute auch einfach
gar nicht leisten, so
wenig
von dem zu machen, was Leute
sich wünschen, weil dann gehen schlicht und ergreifend keine
mehr hin. Und wenn
keiner mehr hingeht, hast du das Problem,
dass das auch irgendwann die Leute checken,
die dort sind, und dass da nicht
nur keiner mehr Neues hingeht, sondern
die Leute, die da sind, auch langsam mit der
Zeit abwandern. Und dann
ist die Kacke am Dampfen dort, ja.
Wie kam es dazu, äh, dazu
vier Tage Woche zu arbeiten?
Da hab ich ein sehr ausführliches Video auf YouTube
gemacht.
Vier Tage Woche, warum die vier Tage?
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es
ich, guck mal,
hier, Teilzeitarbeiten,
die beste Entscheidung, warum die vier Tage
Woche besser ist. So.
Hab ich auf YouTube gemacht,
das kannst du dir angucken.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max und wir haben...
Und das kannst du dir angucken.
Da rede ich, da rede ich
ein bisschen ausführlicher drüber.
Aber kurz und knapp, warum
ich vier Tage Woche mache?
Weil ich's kann. Das ist, glaube ich,
die beste, beste Erklärung, die es da gibt
für, weil, weil's geht,
weil's, weil's
finanziell kein Problem ist
und der ursprüngliche
Gedanke, der ursprüngliche Gedanke
war ja, da hab ich einen Tag mehr
mich um YouTube und Twitch und sowas zu kümmern.
Ist auch weiterhin der
Fall, aber
hauptsächlich geht's mir mittlerweile
um das deutlich
entspanntere Leben mit vier Tage Arbeiten,
drei Tage frei und
aus aktuellen Gesichtspunkten mach ich's eigentlich
nur noch, weil ich's kann.
Und ich seh's auch nicht mehr einig zu machen,
das gibt einige Sachen,
die keinen Spaß mehr machen.
Also ich bin ja auch jemand, der gerne so
Microcontroller bastelt, programmiert,
lötet und sowas. Als Job würde ich das auch
nicht machen wollen.
Das stimmt. Wie gesagt, das ist 20% weniger Urlaub,
ich hab 24 Urlaubstage anstatt 30.
Ähm, doch. Die müssen sogar, also die müssen das nicht in die
Stellenanzeige reinschreiben, aber wenn
du sagst, ich mein, das kann sein, dass das alles erst
ab einer gewissen Betriebsgröße gilt, was ich jetzt sage,
aber normalerweise ist es so, wenn du Vollzeit wo arbeitest
und sagst jetzt, hallo Chef, ich möchte Teilzeit arbeiten,
ich geh davon aus, dass es in einem Fünf-Mann-Betrieb
was anderes ist, ja, bei einem größeren Unternehmen ist
das so, dann sind die dazu verpflichtet, dir das zu
ermöglichen, es sei denn, es sprechen dringende
betriebliche Gründe dagegen, dass es jetzt nicht möglich
ist.
Aber im gleichen Zug müssen die diese Gründe abstellen.
Also, es ist gar nicht so einfach, Teilzeitarbeit zu
verbieten. Das Ding ist halt, realistisch gesehen, kannst
du natürlich sagen, also, kannst du sagen, ich würde gerne
Teilzeit arbeiten, dein Chef sagt, nein, will ich nicht,
dann sagst du, doch, rechtlich gesehen müsst ihr, dann
kündigt dich dein Chef halt. Fristgerecht. Das kann dir
dann natürlich passieren, wenn es so ganz verhärtete,
verhärtete Fronten sind, ja, und das ein kleinerer Laden
ist, wo es auch kein Betriebsrat oder irgendwelche Regelungen
zu sowas gibt, aber in größeren Unternehmen ist das meistens
kein Problem. Oder ab 15 Mitarbeiter, ja, ich weiß es
nicht, aber der Chat ist wieder High IQ, Chat hat wieder
Prime subscribed, die wissen Bescheid. Machst du eigentlich
vier Tage mal sieben Stunden oder acht Stunden, also, also,
nee, mach ich nicht. Ich arbeite 30 Stunden die Woche ungefähr, ich glaube, bis in die
30 Stunden die Woche.
Ungefähr. Ich glaube, ein bisschen mehr.
30,5 oder sowas.
Und 4 Tage.
Achso, 4 Tage, 8 Stunden.
Ja.
7, 7,5 oder
sowas sind es, glaube ich.
Übrigens, ich finde die Diskussionen richtig nice, die aktuell
stattfinden. Habt ihr gelesen, ein paar
Banken in Frankfurt, ich weiß, war es sogar die
Commerzbank? Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Die überlegen, ob sie die 4-Tage-Woche einführen
sollen. Allerdings dann
mit
wie war das?
Nicht exakt der
gleichen Arbeitszeit, aber auch nicht mit
einem Tag weniger Arbeitszeit.
Ich glaube, 50% weniger Arbeitszeit.
Also quasi
anstatt 40 Stunden
nur 35,
aber die dann an 4 Tagen, sowas.
In der Richtung. Also quasi jeden Tag eine Stunde mehr.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die Commerzbank war.
Irgendwelche Banken in Frankfurt.
Habe ich letztens einen Newsartikel drüber gelesen.
Fände ich mega geil, wenn sie das bei mir in der
Versicherung auch einführen.
Weil das bedeutet, für mich, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Ja.
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder, die machen das
und ich bekomme
automatisch mehr Geld, weil ich bin ja
dann schon quasi auf dem
kleineren
Arbeitspensum. Da kriege ich einfach
keine Ahnung, 15%
mehr Geld oder sowas. Soll mir auch
recht sein, ja. Oder
wenn es das nicht gibt, dann sage ich
ja okay, dann gleiche Kohle, aber dann arbeite ich nur 3 Tage.
Also ich bin sofort dabei, wenn die sowas machen wollen.
Das Ding ist halt nur, wenn die mit sowas anfangen.
Ich denke mir es halt so, die haben jetzt schon Probleme, Leute zu finden.
Und wenn du jetzt noch das Ganze reduzierst, dann brauchst du ja im Endeffekt quasi so für
vier Leute einen neuen. Alle vier Leute einen neuen.
Wisst ihr, dass man wieder so auf die auf die gleiche Arbeit kommt, die gepackt wird.
Wobei das ja auch immer fraglich ist.
Es gibt ja Untersuchungen, die sagen, ey Leute, die vier Tage
arbeiten und so und so lang.
Da ist gar kein wirklicher
Arbeitsleistungsunterschied
zu sehen versus fünf Tage.
Dadurch wirst du attraktiver für Bewerber.
Ja, das ist halt die Frage.
Ich weiß, dass das das habe ich mir auch so gedacht.
Das ist halt die Frage, ob dort dann die Schwelle überschritten wird, dass
dass du musst mehr einstellen.
Quasi also die mehr Bewerber durch diesen Vorteil
überwiegt, dass du mehr Leute einstellst.
Überdurchschnittlich mehr Leute bewerben, als du an neuen Stellen brauchst.
Also da weiß ich nicht, ob da die Rechnung aufgeht, falls man, falls sie damit planen.
Aber insgesamt gehe ich von aus, ist das die Zukunft?
Das gibt es bei uns auch.
Aber mir ist es so, ich habe montags fest frei.
Das ist auch von der Zeiterfassung gut.
Bei mir steht einfach in der Zeiterfassung drinne null soll Stunden montags.
Ja, so.
Also Personalführungsverantwortung auch kein Bock drauf.
Ja, ja, so würde ich es ungefähr rechnen.
Lieber Menschen als Windows Server.
Oh, hättest du das als Frage formuliert, hätte ich nicht gewusst, was ich darauf antworten
soll.
Chat, was?
Was wäre euch lieber?
Täglich mit Menschen arbeiten oder Windows Server administrieren?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich weniger gern machen würde.
Das ist ja Horror.
Beides.
Lieber Windows.
Wenn?
Wirklich?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich würde ich mich auch für Windows entscheiden in dem Fall,
wenn ich die Auswahl hätte.
So mit random Menschen jeden Tag.
Aber Windows Server ist halt auch ganz, ganz großer Bullshit.
Der Windows Server nutzen, um Menschen zu kompilieren.
Ja, alles klar.
Ey, mein Nasen juckt, Alter.
Fuck.
Ihr hattet recht, Leute.
Ihr hattet recht.
Ich höre mich komisch an heute.
Sagt bloß, ich habe mich irgendwo angesteckt, ey.
Ragequit.
So.
Ich habe jetzt mal die Nase geputzt.
Ich hoffe ja nicht, dass ich mich irgendwo angesteckt habe.
Das muss ich nicht sagen.
Nächste Welle kommt.
Oh, das brauche ich.
Ich brauche, ey.
Corona will ich auf gar keinen Fall noch machen.
Corona war richtig kacke.
Ich war drei Wochen im Arsch.
Ich habe euch das ja erzählt.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Das habe ich noch nicht erlebt.
Es wäre auch sehr weird, wenn man sagt, wir haben eine Kantine, aber du darfst erst nach
der Probezeit in die Kantine.
Oder wir haben einen Parkplatz, aber da darfst du erst nach der Probezeit parken.
Das ist weird.
Da würde ich mir Gedanken machen, was ist das für ein Laden.
Auf der anderen Seite, in manchen Fällen könnte ich es mir vielleicht sogar vorstellen,
dass das Sinn macht.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Also das habe ich noch nicht erlebt, aber es kommt bestimmt auf den konkreten Fall an.
Ich kann es mir jetzt nicht so wirklich ausmalen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ja des Linux-Desktops!
Ja, endlich!
Wie wäre es mit anderen Menschen beibringen, wie man Windows Server administriert.
Also mal davon abgesehen, dass ich das nicht kann.
Ich möchte also nicht, dass mir jemand beibringt, wie man Windows Server administriert.
Es gibt so zwei Sachen, die mag ich nicht.
Also, anderen...
Mit...
random leuten zusammen irgendwas machen die ich nicht kenne und winters ist hier es gibt auch mehr sachen die ich nicht mag aber das
sind zwei sachen wie macht
Weiß man ja meist nicht also ich weiß wenigstens woher ich meinen corona hatte
ich war damals in frankfurt vor eineinhalb jahren oder wann das war auf dem
warum sagt warum sagen wir in deutschland eigentlich
ironmaiden
die engländer sagen ein
ich verstehe nicht warum das er weggelassen wird aber egal wir sind ja hier
dieser chat ist jetzt deutsch ich war auf einem ironmaiden konzert
im frankfurter stadion
und da haben so viele leute rumgeschrien und dementsprechend sind da wahrscheinlich auch die korona viren rumgeflogen wie sonst was
ich habe schon gleich tag später gemerkt du kriegst das früher oder später auch muss gar nicht probieren daran vorbeizukommen
ich war wenn ihr es schafft
alles gut aber ich
früher stift du fängst dir das an
einmal falsch
eingeatmet an der falschen stelle und sagt hast es
pado heli dankeschön für den sub
34 monate messe
exzellent
exzellent ja ok ja ich meine nachdem das nicht der einzige grund ist warum man dort arbeitet
glaube ich nicht dass es so wild ist oder
Vielleicht ist vielleicht ist das auch fast was langfristig abgeschlossen werden müsste muss je nachdem was da dahinter steckt und dementsprechend wenn die leute potenziell
Da nach sechs monaten wieder weg sind ist halt problematisch
ja vielleicht hast du doch
Glück und schrammst noch dran vorbei an corona ich will auf jeden fall nicht noch ein zweites mal haben das war richtig kacke
ich hatte da immer noch zwei also woche war so richtig einer wochen war so richtig scheiße
und die nächsten nächsten zwei wochen eineinhalb zwei wochen zwei wochen war ich so kaputt
chet erzählt mal
also für alle die auch schon
schon die die ehre hatten ich muss ich sage euch mal wie das bei mir war es
ging dann wieder halbwegs gut ich konnte wieder so ich konnte aus dem bett raus
und sonst wie und da bin ich meine normale so sieht meine normale runde
hier um den main ist ungefähr siebeneinhalb kilometer und ich bin
angefangen die runde zu laufen normalerweise ist überhaupt kein
problem wenn man langsam läuft auch kein problem und ich bin losgelaufen hier
lang über die brücke und habe ich mir gedacht ich kann nicht mehr da muss ich
mich hinsetzen ich wusste mich ernsthaft hinsetzen auf
meiner normalen runde mir ist zum ersten mal aufgefallen wie viele bänke da
eigentlich stehen muss mich hinsetzen und da bin ich umgedreht da habe ich ja
zehn minuten gehockt dann bin ich umgedreht da muss ich mich noch mal
hinsetzen ich war richtig im arsch ja ich war richtig im arsch das auch das
habe ich auch gemerkt ich habe ich habe also es gibt ja leute die sagen man
schmeckt nichts mehr
ich habe schon noch sachen geschmeckt das war wie du wie du das beschreibst
hier ich habe die sachen so anders geschmeckt zwar ganz komisch nicht nur
anders geschmeckt sondern ja dafür ging es aber relativ schnell wieder weg alter
als sein geht meistens nicht wieder weg und das riecht also geschmacks und
geruchssinn war anders mir war es am anfang sogar ein bisschen
schlechter durch weil es total fremd war mir immer
was anstrengend war ist dass ich mich in meinem eigenen wohnung in meinem
eigenen schlafzimmer dadurch das war ganz ganz wird und ist ja wisst ihr was
das einzige war was ich ich habe überhaupt kein appetit überhaupt kein
hunger und ihr wisst da muss schon was schlimmes mit mir sein wenn ich nichts
fressen kann und ich hatte überhaupt keinen appetit kein hunger ich habe da
ich hab da nur rum rumgegammelt und wisst ihr was einzige was das einzige
war was ich essen konnte und was auch noch so ungefähr so geschmeckt hat wie
Ich hatte so aus dem Lidl so Hefezopf, so Gebäckzeug und das habe ich geschnitten mit Lachs.
Nein, nicht Lachs, nicht Nudeln mit Lachs, Chad.
Aber nur, ich habe heute, ich habe heute, stellt euch mal vor, ich habe heute keine Nudeln mit Lachs gegessen.
Ich habe heute Nudeln mit, ich habe heute Nudeln mit Reis, Alter.
Nein, ich habe heute Lachs mit Reis gegessen, tatsächlich.
Nicht Lachs mit Nudeln, Lachs mit Reis.
Ja, ich habe, ich habe so Hefe, Hefezopf, sowas hatte ich vom Lidl da, so ein Ding.
Und nachdem ich drei Tage fast nichts gegessen habe, mit, mit oder, oder fast vier Tage, glaube ich anders sogar,
während Corona fast nichts gegessen habe, dann habe ich diesen Hefe, da habe ich den Hefezopf rausgeholt aus, aus dem Kühlschrank,
habe Quark drauf geschmiert und gefühlt eine halbe, halbe Flasche Honig drüber geschüttet und habe das gefressen.
Und das hat geschmissen.
Geschmeckt, süß, das, das, das habe ich noch geschmeckt.
Das war das Einzige, was normal geschmeckt hat und was leicht verdaulich ist und super viele Kalorien hat, wenn ich,
ich habe da, ich habe quasi dann zwei Tage lang von, ich hatte glücklicherweise nicht schon, nein, von Hefezopf, Quark und massig Honig draufgelebt,
bis es mir wieder besser ging.
Das war mein, mein Corona-Essen.
Bist du wieder vollkommen recovered?
Ja, kein Problem.
Ich bin mehr als recovered.
Also wenn es, wenn es danach geht.
Müsste man den Keck-Alo-Leuten glauben, so nach dem Motto, alles überhaupt kein Problem.
Also ich bin mehr als recovered von Corona.
Ich bin improved, aber nicht durch Corona, sondern weil ich mich mittlerweile mehr bewege und auch mehr Sport mache.
So von Rennen und Fahrradfahren und generell täglich, täglich laufen.
Nicht, nicht täglich joggen, täglich laufen.
Ja, eineinhalb Stunden, eineinhalb Stunden, also eineinhalb Stunden jeden Tag laufen plus jeden zweiten Tag joggen oder alternativ noch einen Tag Pause.
Und dafür dann Fahrrad fahren und jetzt bin ich improved dadurch.
Das hat aber nichts mit Corona zu tun.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob es mein Fahrrad wieder lieferbar gibt.
Weil ich brauche ja, ich brauche ja wieder ein neues Fahrrad.
Wie sieht es denn hier aus?
Größe aus, ausverkauft, okay und in grün.
In grün, ausverkauft, in blau.
Fuck, Alter.
Mein Fahrrad gibt es nicht mehr.
Shit, mal gucken, ob ich jemals wieder ein ordentliches Fahrrad brauche.
Ja gut, es gibt ja noch mehr Hersteller.
Richtig, richtig.
Ich habe, ich habe das neue Mindset, Grindset Mindset, das neue High Performer Mindset, ja.
Wisst ihr, was echt motivierend ist?
Ich habe ja das alles per Fitness Tracker und so drinne und ich gucke mir regelmäßig so die, die, die, die Grafiken an dazu.
Es ist einfach unglaublich motivierend, wenn es Stonks Grafen gibt.
So blöd es klingt, wenn, wenn...
Wenn grüne Pfeile nach oben gehen, ist das motivierend.
Mal bei Rose angefragt für ein Placement.
Ich glaube, da bin ich der falsche Channel für.
Ich mache IT-Zeug und keinerlei Sport-Content.
Ich meine, man könnte gerade aus dem Gesichtspunkt vielleicht sagen, okay,
Rose könnte sich bei mir vielleicht eine komplett neue Schicht an Käufern erschließen.
Ich meine, dann, ich, ich meine, ein Fahrrad, also so, wenn es wirklich auch das Fahrrad ist, so wie ich das haben will,
da würde ich tatsächlich auch ein ausgedehntes Sponsoring mit mir reden lassen zu, ja, würde ich machen.
Ich glaube, das würde auch gar nicht so schlecht ankommen.
Aber das, das nächste Ding ist, ich hätte ja lieber eine 1x12-Schaltung.
Die gibt es gerade noch nicht.
Elektronisch.
Lachs mit Reis, was bei dir falsch?
Ja, es muss mal was anderes sein.
Das Fahrrad mit dem Anime-Paint-Shop.
Ne, das war Canyon, oder?
Hup, what the fuck?
Ken?
Ja?
Was ist das denn?
Oh, Kyo Edition?
Was da?
Genau.
Das wäre das hier.
Ne, das ist, das ist mir, also das, also, ich finde, das sieht mega nice aus, obwohl ich jetzt nicht so der Ultra-Weep bin.
Ich finde, das sieht mega nice aus.
Das Fahrrad würde ich mir aber nicht holen, weil es eine deutlich für mich zu sportliche Sitzposition hat.
Rose kann, selbst Rose könnte das gar nicht machen.
Weil es die Schaltung noch nicht,
gibt.
Shimano hat aktuell bloß eine 1x12-Schaltung.
Mechanisch.
Und ich hätte gerne eine elektronische 1x12-Schaltung.
Die gibt es doch nicht.
Und auf SRAM habe ich aus anderen Gründen keinen Bock.
Zum Beispiel, weil die oben keine Buttons haben.
Das finde ich sehr nice, dass du bei Shimano oben Buttons hast, wo du deinen Fahrradcomputer steuern kannst am Lenker, ohne dass du drauf touchen musst oder dran greifen musst.
Ja.
Also, ich finde optisch sieht das mega cool aus.
Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Musik, Pock.
Kennt ihr das?
Wenn ihr manchmal Probleme habt zu pennen, kommt ja ab und zu mal vor.
Es ist nicht, als hätte ich Schlafstörungen oder sowas.
Ja, aber manchmal hast du irgendwie, machst dir Gedanken oder denkst du über was nach.
Oder hast zu viel Noobs gebasht, bevor du ins Bett gehst und bist noch aufgeregt.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, manchmal kann man nicht richtig pennen.
Und da liegt man so im Bett und es klappt nichts.
Und da macht man sich ein YouTube-Video an und anstatt dabei einzupennen, hört man eher beim YouTube-Video zu und kann nicht richtig pennen.
Zumindest, was bei mir oft hilft ist, wenn ich mir Sachen mit Sounds anmache, die ich früher quasi gehört habe.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich mir ein Mario 64 Let's Play anmache oder sowas.
Einfach die Sounds von dem Game im Hintergrund.
Die beruhigen mich, da penne ich fast in Zimt ein.
Oder auch irgendwelche Super Nintendo Games oder sowas.
Wenn es was ist, wo ich irgendwie eine Erinnerung im Kopf habe, so wie ich früher im Wohnzimmer gesessen habe und gespielt habe oder so.
Sobald ich das anmache und da so ein bisschen dabei zuhöre, da ratze ich direkt weg.
Bei mir hilft alles komplett dunkel, keine Medien, kein Licht, nichts.
Ja, genau sowas meine ich.
Sowas meine ich im Prinzip.
Ja, bei dir könnte es das sein.
Bei mir ist es vielleicht irgendwelche Super...
Super Nintendo Games Sounds oder so.
Also das war früher bei mir ähnlich.
Das Problem ist nur, ich habe es mir komplett versaut, seit ich angefangen habe Streaming und YouTube Videos im Bett zu gucken.
Seitdem kann ich nicht mehr pennen, ohne dass was läuft.
Ich habe mehr oder weniger die gesamte Nacht irgendwas laufen mittlerweile.
Sei es nur irgendwelche Chill-Music-Listen oder irgendwelche...
News aus dem Weltall, das Universum, eineinhalb Stunden Doku oder sowas, was ich auch, was ich auch mir gerne angucke sind Mathe-Vorlesungen von der Uni.
Also angucke ist, ist, ist falsch, falsches, falsches Wort, ja, an, unterbewusst anhören und dabei pennen.
Ich glaube, ich bin der Einzige, der bei Mathe-Vorlesungen so gut schlafen kann, Alter.
Ich schlafe auch gar nicht mehr.
Also ich penne.
Also ich kann meistens auch.
Ich kann auch wie ein Stein pennen, ja.
Aber manchmal geht es nicht, selten.
Aber meistens bin ich instant weg.
Und schlafe dann auch gut.
Es ist schon 10.
Richtig, richtig.
Aber heute habe ich ein bisschen länger Zeit.
Ja, ich kann das nicht mehr.
Ich kann das nicht mehr.
Ich habe auch gemerkt, ganz, ganz weird, eigentlich würde man es umgedreht vermuten.
Wenn es zu leise ist im Schlafzimmer, dann träume ich komische Sachen.
So richtig, so richtig weirden Shit.
Ich habe letztens geträumt, das ist ganz abgedrehtes Zeug, ja.
Als es meiner Katze nicht gut ging, habe ich, habt ihr ja mitbekommen, als meiner Katze nicht gut ging, also muss ich jetzt, eines der ersten Sachen, wo ich mitbekommen habe, dass es meiner Katze nicht gut ging, die Katze hat zu hohen Blutdruck gehabt, ist, oder es äußert sich bei Katzen oftmals, dass die so kleine Blutungen im Auge haben, an der Seite, ganz klein sieht man kaum.
Das wird bei Katzen oft durch zu hohen Blutdruck verursacht.
Und.
Ich weiß noch, in einer Nacht, nachdem das war, ich meine, macht man sich natürlich Gedanken um seine Katz und sowas.
Irgendwann hatte ich mal nachts keine Musik und nix laufen.
Und da weiß ich noch, da habe ich geträumt, dass meine Katze vor mir gestanden hat und ihr die Augen geplatzt sind.
Und da hatte ich, übelst bin ich, bin ich dann zu mir gekommen und war übelst fertig, ey.
Ja, richtig MonkaS, Mann.
Da habe ich auch gedacht, boah, Alter, Max, was?
Was ist los?
Und dann, dann bin ich aufgewacht und habe festgestellt, es ist einfach nur dunkel und leise.
Und danach habe ich mir ein bisschen Chill-Musik auf dem Handy angemacht und habe danach super geschlafen, ohne irgendeinen Shit zu träumen.
Also, ich brauche, ich brauche Hintergrundgeräusche, sonst träume ich komisches Zeug.
Also, man träumt teilweise schon echt abartigen Kram, so.
Regengeräusche, ja.
Das habe ich auch mal gemacht, ähm, da gibt es dann so zehn, zehn Stunden tropischer, tropischer Regen.
Ja.
Ich hatte mal vor einer ganzen Weile, wo ich mich noch nicht so viel bewegt habe, wo ich öfters mal so Verspannungen und Rückenprobleme hatte,
da hatte ich mal zwei, drei Wochen so ein Piepsgeräusch im Ohr, das kam so von Nackenmuskelverspannungen und sowas.
Und das hat mich so, das hat mich so genervt und damit ich das quasi nicht hören musste,
habe ich mir auf dem Handy tropische Regenfälle angemacht, neben das Ohr gelegt, auf der rechten oder linken, ich weiß gar nicht, es war,
es war rechts, äh, neben, neben das Ohr gelegt, und das, dieses, dieses Rauschen vom Regen, das war das Einzige, wo ich, wie man das, wie das nachts nicht gestört hat.
Also, es hat, ein paar Sachen habe ich schon gelernt, dadurch, dass ich nachts beim Schlafen Mathevorlesungen höre, aber viel nicht.
Oh je.
War das gut oder schlecht, übrigens, ein sehr cutes Emote?
Und, wie war das so?
War das eher, war das eher gut oder schlecht?
Hehehe.
Ja, gibt Leute, die pennen da auch vor Ort.
Wie importierst du deine .files eigentlich?
Das mache ich damit.
Also, erst einmal, meine .files gibt es auf Shithub hier.
Ich müsste mal wieder pushen, ist schon ein Jahr her.
Und, die verwalte ich mit, schätze, ohne jetzt zu wissen, ob man das so ausspricht.
Schätzmoi.
Das ist Pocktool, ja.
Du hast mal Enterprise Brückenambiente ausprobiert.
Was darf ich mal unter Enterprise, also Brückenambiente, da stelle ich mir nichts Gutes drunter vor, so
Frankfurt der S-Bahn Brücke oder so, aber was sind Enterprise Brücken?
Ach, ach, Star Trek, jetzt verstehe ich das, so Raumschiff, Raumschiff Brückenambiente.
Ach, das, okay.
Ja, das ist ja meistens auch so weißes, weißes, dumpfes Rauschen so.
Mir fällt gerade auf, Chat.
Morgen ist ja Sonntag, da machen wir ja schon direkt wieder aufwachen, streamen morgen früh.
Was ist da los?
Das heißt, ich gehe jetzt offline, penne und dann wird wieder gestreamt.
Gut, dass ich das Video für morgen schon hochgeladen habe, ich muss es nur noch freischalten.
Kannst du die i3-Config zeigen?
Ich will mir die CPU-Anzeige kopieren.
Du gehst auf GitHub in meinen .files Ordner, dann gehst du auf .config, i3-Config,
und dann ist es höchstwahrscheinlich das hier, ja, wird vielleicht nicht eins zu eins
bei dir so funktionieren wegen dem Kram hier drin, da kannst du aber rausschmeißen.
Die CPU-Anzeige kommt ja von dem Statusbar-Plugin, das ist das hier, das ist, äh, was ist denn
hier?
CPU-Layout, das da ist es, glaube ich.
Das ist übrigens mega nice.
Die CPU-Anzeige, wenn man mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen CPU-Last verursacht, hier guckt,
dann seht ihr, das sind acht verschiedene Cores, oder wie viele Cores haben wir, acht, glaube
ich, acht verschiedene Cores und du siehst halt, wie die einzelnen Cores ausgelastet
sind.
Das ist so ein richtig, so ein richtig Mini-Taskmanager, kann man nicht sagen, aber so richtig Mini-Anzeige,
die sich halt sehr gut widerspiegelt, wo hier was ausgelastet ist.
Finde ich gut.
Fällt mir.
Na gut, deswegen habe ich es vielleicht ja auch, ne?
Ist so kramm.
Ah ja, Frankfurt, wenn ich an Brücke denke, denke ich Frankfurt der S-Bahn-Brücke oder
sowas.
Was sind die drei Zahlen davor?
Das ist Load.
Load unter Linux ist immer, Load, oh fuck, jetzt nicht, dass ich Mist erzähle.
Load ist immer eine Minute, fünf Minuten, nee.
Fünf, nee, was ist, wie ist die Anzahl?
Wie ist die Anzeige von Load?
30 Sekunden, eine Minute, fünf Minuten oder fünf Sekunden, eine Minute, fünf Minuten
oder 1,3,5, ich weiß es gar nicht.
Ja, das ist die, die Load über eine gewisse Zeit, also die, aktuell habe ich eine relativ
hohe Load gehabt, kurzzeitig, weil ich habe ja, siehst du ja, wenn ich hier kurz, wenn
ich hier mal Load verursache, dann geht die kurzzeitige Load hoch, aber die Load über
die letzten drei und 15 Minuten geht.
Halt kaum hoch, weil, ist halt nicht viel, aber wenn ich das wieder ausmache, dann.
Dementsprechend, wenn es mal lange Zeit hoch war, geht die auch langsam mal wieder runter.
1,5, 15 sind es, ja, was denn, jetzt habe ich drei Sachen zur Auswahl.
Chatgeben.
Kennst du eine gute Seite, um Gehaltsdurchschnitte für ID-Jobs anzuzeigen, am besten mit Kriterien,
da gibt es ein paar, aber ich habe da noch keine gefunden, wo ich sagen würde, oh ja,
das, da würde ich mich drauf verlassen.
Was ich immer gut finde ist.
Andere Leute fragen, wie es bei ihnen so ist, am besten halt, sagen wir mal, ähnliche
Region, ähnlicher Job, zum Beispiel meinen Twitch-Chat könntest du fragen, wie es da
aussieht.
Also, wir haben ja öfters mal das Thema Einstiegsgehalt, Einstiegsgehalt, je nachdem was es ist, kann
ich auch nicht viel zu sagen, das einzige, was ich den Leuten dann immer erzählen kann
ist, mein Einstiegsgehalt hochgerechnet, wenn du da mal Inflation und alles mit einrechnest,
mein Einstiegsgehalt hochgerechnet auf 2024 und das sind glaube ich 46.000 €, also damals
waren es 33.500 €.
Ich denke, das ist gerade für Frankfurt und Umgebung eine ganz gute Hausnummer.
Ja, das ist so, aber das machen wir hier nicht, sondern wir reden hier ganz normal drüber.
Hier ist es ja auch ein bisschen anonym, deswegen ist das kein Problem, außer, außer dein Nickname
auf Twitch ist zufälligerweise dein Wörter.
Ja, das ist ja auch ein bisschen anonym, deswegen ist das kein Problem, außer, außer dein Nickname auf Twitch ist zufälligerweise dein Wörter.
Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, was der Vor- und der Nachname ist.
Guck mal, ob es neue Package-Updates gibt.
Wir haben ja 8 Linux, by the way.
32K für 48 Stunden, in welchem Bereich?
Also, für was?
Also 32K ist in der Tat enorm wenig.
Gerade in Berlin, wo wahrscheinlich mit 32K du 100% dafür aufwenden musst,
von dem, was sie dir aufs Konto überweisen, dass du überhaupt deine Wohnung bezahlen kannst.
Oh, das ist doch nice.
Ich habe jetzt Februar Zwischenprüfung Physik.
Quatsch. Zwischenprüfung, easy.
Hast du schon alte Prüfungen gemacht?
Freddy, du musst alte Prüfungen machen.
Wenn du noch keine alten Prüfungen gemacht hast, dann hast du zu Recht Schiss davor.
Wenn du schon alte Prüfungen gemacht hast und die gut laufen, musst du keinen Schiss davor haben.
Hast du denn schon alte Prüfungen gemacht?
Postchamp?
Ich postchamp jetzt, bis er antwortet.
Nicht unter Druck gesetzt fühlen?
Habe ich. Genau deswegen hast du aber...
Wieso schneidest du nicht gut ab bei den alten Prüfungen?
Dann gibt es einfach einen weiteren Trick.
Noch mehr alte Prüfungen machen, bis man gut abschneidet.
Ich sage dir jetzt mal ehrlich, wie es ist.
Die IHK-Prüfung.
Wenn du die Auswahl hast zwischen zwei Leuten.
Einer, der die Ausbildung gemacht hat, 3,5 Jahre, oder eigentlich 3,5.
2,5 bis 3 Jahre und sich richtig Mühe gegeben hat, richtig Ahnung hat.
Ohne spezielle Vorbereitung auf die Prüfung.
Versus jemand, der die Ausbildung nicht gemacht hat und sich einfach zwei Monate mit täglich Prüfungslernen vorbereitet.
Also ich würde auf den Typ wetten, der zwei Monate am Stück Prüfungen gemacht hat und eigentlich gar keinen Plan hat.
Wer die bessere Abschlussprüfung schreibt.
Das heißt, es geht bei der Abschlussprüfung und bei der Zwischenprüfung weniger darum, dass du ein guter Fisi bist.
Und fachlich Ahnung hast.
Sondern es geht darum, dass du IHK-Deutsch verstehst.
Und das hinschreibst.
Das, was die IHK wissen will.
Egal, wie viel oder wie wenig das mit deinem täglichen Arbeitsablauf, mit deinen täglichen Aufgaben, mit der Realität an sich zu tun hat.
Du musst IHK-Prüfungen lernen und IHK-Prüfungsmäßig halt die Dinger beantworten, so wie die das hören wollen.
Dann ist gut.
Und das kriegt jeder hin, der sich ein bisschen vorbereitet.
Da musst du dir keine Gedanken machen.
Du musst dir bloß unbedingt alte Prüfungen angucken.
So lang, bis du diesen IHK-Style, der Freizeit.
Fragestellung gecheckt hast.
Ja, genau so sind die Fragen gestellt.
Genauso wird's in die Fragen gestellt.
Arbeitest ausschließlich mit Mac.
Doch gut.
Die ganzen SQL-Fragen und die fachlichen...
Ja, aber das ist doch jedes Jahr.
Ist das doch immer mehr oder weniger das Gleiche, was da dran kommt.
Und ein bisschen SQL-Zeug...
Kann man schon können als Fisi.
Unabhängig davon, ob man auf dem Mac arbeitet oder nicht.
Ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Bei der IHK gibt's alles.
Wie tiefgehend sind die SQL-Fragen da?
Kann mich ehrlich gesagt nicht mal dran erinnern.
Wie tiefgreifend sind die SQL-Fragen in der IHK-Prüfung?
Die können nicht sonderlich kompliziert sein, weil ich hab's ja offensichtlich geschafft.
Und ich bin echt kacke, was SQL angeht.
Okay, mein MSSQL-Syntax drin ist ja auch verloren.
Ich hätte aber, was SQL angeht, schon bei deutlich einfacheren Sachen verloren.
Also das höchste...
Das höchste der Gefühle, was ich hinbekomme in SQL, ist ein Join.
Aber dann auch nur mit Gespicke.
Also ich krieg kein Join...
Also nur mit Autocomplete.
Mit Autocomplete krieg ich ein Join hin, ansonsten nicht.
Das ist aber wirklich das...
Das ist aber das Maximum an SQL, was ich hinkrieg.
Händisch.
Ja, sowas machen die gerne.
Was die auch gerne in Abschlussprüfungen machen,
ordnen sie die Gefahrensymbole zu.
Alter, die IHK noch nicht mal Bilder dazu findet, Mann.
Kriegste dann...
Kriegste dann solche Dinge angezeigt und sollst wissen, was es ist und so.
Das ist eine Frage, die kriegst du als Fisi gestellt.
Richtig.
Das ist das eigentliche Problem da dran.
Dass sie so IHK-Style gestellt sind, die Fragen.
Das ist das, woran man sich gewöhnen muss.
Damit bekommst du aber keine Punkte bei der IHK.
Wie gesagt, realistische, 2024 bezogene Antworten gelten bei der IHK-Prüfung nicht.
Da muss genau das hin, was die hören wollen.
Ich muss das auch, ich musste das auch machen.
Ich musste, ich hab ja dort, wo ich jetzt neu angefangen hab,
musste ich ja auch mindestens sieben verschiedene Security-Schulungen und Unterweisungen durchklicken und besuchen.
Und da kam auch dran, Gefahrensymbole einordnen.
Chat, wie ist die Rettungs...
Wie heißt das Ding? Rettungskette?
So mit Notarzt und selbst in Sicherheit bringen und Notarzt und...
Heißt das nicht Rettungskette?
Nicht Rettungsgasse, nein.
Nein, das meine ich nicht.
Rettung, heißt das nicht Rettungskette?
Heißt denn das...
Heißt Rettungskette, oder?
Absichern, Eigenschutz, Notruf, Sofortmaßnahmen, Erste Hilfe, Rettungsdienst, genau.
Rettungskette, ey.
Ja, das muss man dann da...
Auch, ich...
Ich hab übrigens schon gehört, dass bei uns auf der Arbeit, dass man cheaten kann.
Bei diesen...
Tests.
Und zwar sind wohl die Tests jedes Jahr die gleichen.
Nur die Reihenfolge der Frage ist anders.
Das heißt, wir haben manche Leute, die haben sich einfach Screenshots vom Fragebogen gemacht und klicken das nächstes Jahr wieder durch.
Sollte ich vielleicht auch machen.
Ich meine, der Lerneffekt ist dann zwar weg, aber damit kann ich leben.
Ich hab tatsächlich diese Schulungsseite mit DevTools noch nie angeguckt.
Sollte ich vielleicht mal machen, ja.
Easy findest du die Antworten im Internet, ja, ja.
Um welche Tests geht's?
Ja.
Man muss auf der Arbeit, zumindest ich musste das, ist Pflicht, dass man einmal im Jahr ein paar so...
Wie nennt sich diese übergeordnete Kategorie von Tests?
Keine Ahnung.
Da muss man so Sicherheitsunterweisungen machen und danach muss man so einen Multiple-Choice-Test ausfüllen, dass man verstanden hat, wie man beim Brandfall aus dem Gebäude kommt oder wie man Terroristen erkennt.
Ohne Scheiß, das war eine Frage bei uns.
Ähm...
Nee, also nicht, wie man Terroristen erkennt, aber dass man, dass man, nee, was war die, genau, dass, dass, dass man Leute melden soll, dass man, dass man Leute melden soll, die verdächtige, verdächtige Aktivitäten im Gebäude durchführen und sowas.
Und da hatten sie dann bei so einem, bei einem Bild stand halt so ein Koffer rum, so.
Was sagt ihr dazu?
Moment, was sagt ihr dazu?
Nach der IT-Kaufmann und drei Jahre Berufserfahrung noch ein Wirtschaftsinformatikstudium anzuschließen.
Das musst du wissen, das kann man nicht pauschal sagen.
Willst du dir wirklich noch ein Studium geben und wenn ja, warum?
Was ist dein Hintergedanke, warum willst du das Studium machen?
Ist es das Geld?
Da kann man nur sagen, im Durchschnitt, statistisch gesehen, mag sich das lohnen.
Im Durchschnitt verdient jemand, der studiert hat, mehr als jemand, der nicht studiert hat.
Im Einzelfall für dich muss sich das nicht unbedingt lohnen.
Es ist immer die Frage, warum du das machen willst.
Und ob du die Muße dazu hast, dir das nochmal zu geben.
Ob du wirklich mehr Gehalt kriegst, kommt auf dich an.
Also das ist, wie gesagt, im Durchschnitt verdienst du mehr, wenn du studiert hast.
Für dich im Einzelfall muss das nicht der Fall sein.
Wenn du jetzt Ahnung hast von dem, was du machst, kannst du jetzt auch gut Kohle verdienen, ohne dass du studiert hast.
Und durchaus mehr als jemand, der studiert hat, aber nicht so den Durchblick hat.
Das kann man echt schwierig sagen.
Ich würde es davon abhängig machen.
Also für mich kommt das gar nicht mehr in Frage.
Ich hätte da gar keine, wie soll man sagen, nicht das passende Mindset für, nicht die Ausdauer zu.
Es ist die Frage, ob du dir das nochmal wirklich geben willst.
Weil es ist schon nicht ohne.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Ne, es macht durchaus Sinn, solche Schulungen durchzuführen, sehe ich auch so.
Zu lustig, die sich teilweise erstmal anhören und die Bildchen da drin aussehen, das macht schon Sinn.
Normale Informatik ist aber deutlich schwieriger nochmal, weil das quasi ein Mathe-Studium ist, mit ein bisschen Computer-Zeug dabei, erst mal.
Auf manche Stellen brauchst du dich ohne gar nichts zu bewerben.
Ehrlich, mir fällt jetzt von den letzten, boah, 100 Stellenanzeigen oder so, die wir uns angeguckt haben, nicht eine ein, die explizit jemand haben wollten, der studiert ist.
Meistens ist das vollkommen egal.
Ich meine, bei irgendeinem Amt vielleicht, aber ansonsten so gut wie gar nicht.
Gibt Leute, die machen mit 30 nochmal eine Ausbildung.
Na, wenn schon, muss die andere Seite das mit einrechnen.
Du musst dich einfach nur gut verkaufen.
Und wenn es für den jeweiligen Beruf passt, kann man ruhig ein bisschen darauf rumreiten, dass man da schon Vorkenntnisse hat, die man auch insofern belegen kann und sie dementsprechend quasi auch nicht die Kuh im Sack kaufen.
Ne, wie heißt das?
Die Katze im Sack.
Nicht die Kuh im Sack.
Wie heißt das Sprechwort mit der Kuh?
Die Katze im Sack kaufen.
Weil du davon ja Ahnung hast.
Aber ansonsten, ich persönlich finde ja Zertifikate meistens enorm unsinnig und die ganze, dieses ganze Zertifikats-Ökosystem finde ich unsinnig.
Aber mag sicherlich den einen oder anderen geben, der darauf Wert legt.
Ich würde es nicht machen und ich glaube bei den meisten Unternehmen ist das zumindest kein festes so Kriterium, so nach dem Motto, wir nehmen niemanden ohne Zertifikat.
So, ich kann noch was nachgucken.
Die Kuh vom Eis, genau.
Kann sein.
Kenn ich nicht.
Vielleicht bei irgendwelchen BWL-Sachen oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Was manche Kunden vielleicht verlangen ist, dass du DIN-ISO irgendwas zertifiziert bist oder so.
Das muss dann aber nicht du sein, sondern der Laden, in dem du arbeitest.
Also, wie gesagt, ich persönlich halte ja von Zertifikaten gar nichts.
Chat, ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Morgen früh aufwachen, streamen.
Kann sein, dass ich erst wieder am Ende so meines normalen Online-Comments bin.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht, warum Zeitfensters da bin, weil ich wieder meine 11-Kilometer-Runde mache morgen früh.
Zumindest geplant nach jetzigem Zeitstand, ja.
Das heißt, wenn ich dann aufstehe, so, keine Ahnung, kurz vor 8, bin ich eine Stunde am Rennen.
Kurz vor 9.
Ich muss noch ein bisschen was essen.
Könnte dann durchaus eine Ecke nach 9 werden.
Ring erinnern, ja.
Da habe ich gerade schon Bock.
Ja.
Aber ich glaube, dann wird es jetzt echt Zeit.
Also, Leute, bis morgen.
Macht's gut.
See you.